-Making her U.S. TV debut,
performing "Woman"
from her upcoming album,
"Sometimes I Might Be
Introvert,"
here's Little Simz!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Ooh-ooh, ooh ♪
♪ Ooh-ooh, ooh ♪
-♪ Naija women
got the melanin drippin' ♪
♪ L-O-N-D-O-N,
city-girl livin' ♪
♪ In the back, looking like
fire, chili pepper ♪
♪ Yoruba girl tougher than
imperial leather ♪
♪ He was getting bitter,
she was getting better ♪
♪ Diamonds are forever ♪
♪ Miss Sierra Leone looking
like a gem ♪
♪ Works hard in the week,
party on the weekend ♪
♪ Know you wanna live with
no one watching how you spend ♪
♪ Got a thing for the finer
things and the finer men, ha ♪
♪ Miss Tanzania,
she a do-or-die ♪
♪ Say she want to know more
'bout the Sukuma tribe ♪
♪ We hit the...once
wasn't enough ♪
♪ I've got an ocean full of
knowledge you could scuba-dive ♪
♪ Miss Ethiopia
can play so jazzy ♪
♪ Then sit you down
and school you on Selassie ♪
♪ Tell 'em you're nothing
without a woman ♪
♪ Woman to woman,
I wanna see you glow ♪
Sing!
-♪ I love
how you go
from zero to one hundred ♪
♪ And leave the dust behind ♪
♪ You've got this ♪
♪ All action, no talk ♪
-♪ My Bajan honeys, know you
repping for your country ♪
♪ Sun kissing your brown skin,
looking like money ♪
♪ Say she focusing on
being an accountant ♪
♪ When you have
beauty and brains,
they find it astounding ♪
♪ Why, she been getting it
on her own ♪
♪ Self-made, ain't nobody
doing gold digger ♪
♪ Now, Miss India always speaks
with her chest ♪
♪ Got respect from her people
'cause she leads them the best ♪
♪ Ha, real-life queen
in the flesh ♪
♪ Know the crown get heavy,
still it be's on your head ♪
♪ My Brooklyn ladies,
know you hustle on the daily ♪
♪ Innovating just like
Donna Summer in the '80's ♪
♪ Your time,
they seeing you glow now ♪
♪ Intelligence and elegance,
show 'em how ♪
♪ Miss Jamaica understand
food for the soul ♪
♪ When she get up in the kitchen
or she throw down ♪
♪ Ain't nothing
without a woman ♪
♪ Woman to woman,
I wanna see you glow ♪
Sing!
-♪ I love
how you go
from zero to one hundred ♪
♪ And leave the dust behind ♪
♪ You've got this ♪
♪ All action, no talk ♪
-♪ I see you glow ♪
-♪ You're the finest gold ♪
-♪ When they walk in the room ♪
-♪ They feel your soul ♪
-♪ Your style, it shines ♪
-♪ So ahead of time ♪
-♪ And you know
that you're fire ♪
-♪ You're so damn fine, girl ♪
-♪ Girl, girl, girl, girl ♪
-♪ She a Ghana girl ♪
♪ Calm with it, never let
the green plant fail ♪
♪ Though a sucker for
the romance,
take you to the homeland ♪
♪ One way,
she ain't coming back ♪
♪ All I see is black stars
and I friggin' love it ♪
♪ Time's up, tell the people
that we comin' ♪
♪ Done being in the shadow,
going public, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Don't know how to bear it,
how to stomach, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Hand over this
and let us run it, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ All we know
is looking flawless,
all they know is stare, stare ♪
♪ Ain't nothing without
a woman, though ♪
♪ Woman to woman,
I just wanna see you glow ♪
Sing!
-♪ I love
how you go
from zero to one hundred ♪
♪ And leave the dust behind ♪
♪ You've got this ♪
♪ And lead them
with your light ♪
-Hey!
♪ Woman to woman,
I wanna see you glow ♪
♪ Tell 'em what's up ♪
-♪ La, la-la, la ♪
♪ La-la, la ♪
♪ La, la-la, la ♪
-♪ La-la, la, la, la, la ♪
♪ La-la, la, la, la-la, la ♪
♪ Boom, boom, boom,
boom, boom, boom ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]